mask on
yeah dramatic video shows
lawmakers and staff inside the house
chambers rioters stormed the building
yesterday afternoon
now some lawmakers were trapped on the
second floor that's known as the house
gallery
after representatives on the first floor
were evacuated
you can actually hear what sounds like
gunshots and see lawmakers hiding behind
the gallery railing
as some of them even put on emergency
masks now we have an image that shows
representative take a look at this this
is jason crowe from colorado
and representative susan wilde oh my
goodness of pennsylvania crouching down
together
they join us now to talk about that i'm
so glad that the two of you are okay i
listen guys i thought it was
traumatizing just seeing the picture
sitting in the safety of my home at from
my kitchen table
i can't imagine what it was like for the
two of you jason if you would start us
off please
congressman crowe what exactly is
happening in this moment
well this is the moment where we got
trapped in the house chamber they had
evacuated leadership
as soon as the outer court on the
security barrier had been broken at the
capitol
and they evacuated the members who were
on the house floor and then they started
to evacuate us but by that point
uh the uh mob the rioters had broken in
and had surrounded the chamber so they
uh closed the doors and we had to lock
the doors and started to barricade them
to prevent
uh the mob from getting in and they were
they were trying to ram down the doors
and we were
at that point thinking we might have to
fight our way out you're clearly
comforting your colleague there at that
moment why did you think that was
necessary
my heart goes out to you susan while
because i could see the concern on your
face jason what were you thinking as you
looked at her
well i mean susan is my friend and um
you know i was uh
upset about the situation she was upset
about it and
i did what i think any friend would want
to do and i just
let her know that i was there for her
and that we would get through it
yeah susan what was going through your
mind at that moment did you think your
life was in danger at that particular
time
i i think i did believe that there was
chaos and confusion i had never been in
a situation like that unlike my
colleague here who's been in combat
situations i had
not it was terribly concerning that
photograph was actually
first sent to me by my adult son
who texted it to me later in the day
needless to say that's not
what you want your children to see you
facetimed your children during this
didn't you what did you say to them what
did you say
i actually that's my daughter yeah that
you're showing on the screen
her name and um yes i asked my children
to call me and
we facetimed very briefly i didn't know
what was going to happen next
and i wanted to make sure that i had
some communication with them
it was the the last thing in the world i
wanted to do i was afraid that
it would just terrorize them but at the
same time if the worst happened i didn't
want them to not
have heard from me as a child to see
your parents in that situation i know
that was very upsetting we understand
that you all were taken
to a secure location can you say now
where that was
how many people were in the room and
what did you all talk about at that
moment
well we were taken to the ways and means
committee room which is probably the
largest committee room um it's over in
longworth
and i would say at its peak there were
about
somewhere close to 400 people in there
mostly members but some staff
it wasn't nearly big enough as a room
considering the current pandemic
and social distancing issues and so
forth there were an awful lot of
unmasked members republicans who were
specifically asked
to put their masks on that just added
another layer of stress to a very very
stressful day did you talk about how you
were going to proceed
after all of this ended
well i think we're still processing what
exactly happened and i think um
you know as i i have about three hours
of sleep under my belt right now i think
susan has about the same
uh but as i've reflected more on it um
frankly i'm pretty angry right now
i'm angry about the traitors who
stormed the capitol you called this a
coup on twitter
yeah that that was their intent to stop
the transition of power i don't know
what else to call it
that's what was happening they delayed
it but they did not stop it because our
democracy and our government
is stronger than these uh these
treasonous
uh traitors uh but they need to be
brought to justice and they need to be
brought to justice fast
are you angry at the president too
congressman crow
many believe he incited this can you
talk about that
well there's it's not it's not a
question of whether or not uh they
believe he incited that this isn't a
question of the tooth fairy or or santa
claus
uh he did incite this directly these are
his words
he did it he is a violent man he's an
ill man
but this is not a story about donald
trump anymore because we have known for
many many years
who he is there should come as no
surprise
this is really a story of the enablers
the members of congress
the inner circle the members who have
allowed us to get to this point
were you are you concerned that that
this happened
i mean that this was allowed to happen
in the first place how did you feel
that capitol police responded and how do
you feel the city
police responded you know that's
that's something that still remains to
be determined
we were inside the building the entire
day so we didn't have the opportunity to
see what was happening but we have since
seen video
and clips and it's very concerning
um as i said to jason just before we
came on the show
it's not just about the safety of
members of congress but in the average
day when we're not in
a pandemic thousands of members of the
public
are scattered throughout the capital the
idea
that that building can be stormed so
easily
and that security can be overcome and
and literally
take over the capitol for an extended
period of time this wasn't just a brief
thing you've seen the pictures of these
people
scattered throughout the building taking
pictures of themselves
with you know so very very concerning
for
for all of us yeah thank you for the
reminder that we're in the middle of a
pandemic
yeah people need to know listen we're
still living in very dangerous times
representatives jason crowe and susan
wilde thank you both
for joining us this morning and we are
glad you are okay
thank you so much and